78254 x 99999 try solving this in five
seconds
your time starts now there's no chance
you could have done it in five seconds
if you use the traditional method let's
see how much time I take seven eight two
five three two one seven four six yes
that's the correct answer and you may
verify it using your calculator now you
may be thinking that I knew the answer
before hand but what if I prove it to
you that you two can solve such
questions in five seconds or less let's
see how we try out smaller numbers first
16 x 99 first we make a partition to get
the number on the Left we subtract a 1
from 16 16 minus 1 we write a 15 here
and on the right we simply subtract this
15 from 99 so 99 minus 15 on the right
we get 15 down and 99 minus 15 is 84
that's the correct answer
16 times 99 is 1584 here's another one
23 times 99 give it a try we make a
partition 23 minus 1 is 22 and on the
right we subtract this from 99 99 minus
20 to get 22 down and 99 minus 22 is 77
23 times 99 is 2277 notice that we are
taking approximately five seconds to
answer these questions but wait will
anything change if we have three-digit
numbers instead say we have something
like 256 times 999 no the technique
crumby is exactly
same we make a partition first on the
Left we have 256 minus 1 which is 255
and on the right we have 999 - 255 don't
make the mistake of subtracting this
number from 999 it's the number we get
here that we need to subtract from 999
okay so we get 255 down nine minus five
is four nine minus five is four again
and nine minus two is seven that's the
correct answer
256 times 999 is equal to 255 thousand
seven hundred and forty four and here's
the last one I want you guys to try you
will definitely get it right and if you
get this right you will be extremely
confident about this method I give you
ten seconds got it right doesn't matter
even if you did not I'm sure you're
learning subtracting a one from this we
get forty-nine thousand six hundred and
twenty-four and on the right we will
have 99999 minus forty-nine thousand six
hundred and twenty-four then we get
forty-nine thousand six hundred
twenty-four down and then we solve this
9 minus 4 is 5
nine minus 9 is 0 9 minus 6 is 3 9 minus
2 is 7 and 9 minus 4 is 5
I know we should ideally go from right
to left while subtracting but here all
the digits on top are 9 they will
definitely be larger than the digits of
the number at the bottom so we don't
really need to worry about that so this
is the product of these two numbers and
you may verify it using a calculator if
you wish to but did you observe
something in all the cases the number of
nines is the same as the number of
digits in the number two
- 2 + 2 3 + 3 5 + 5
what if they're not the same something
like 16 times 999 or 1537 times 99 will
this technique change we will see that
over the next few sessions but if they
are the same the technique is simple
subtract 1 to get a result on the left
and then subtract that result from 99 or
999 or 9999 and so on
you